this guy's got a king of their sting it
for us
hey what's up theo what's up onion
where'd you even buy that shirt
it's a great where would you buy that
shirt i honestly genuinely my hard
belief he bought that at a cvs
you think cbs or or at a trump rally
100 hey what's up the uh what's up onion
um this is clark from bisbee arizona
um you can my friends call me clark and
so i want to say this guys what do you
guys think king intersting it
you know um
what do you think about these underwater
births
of babies a lot of women now you see
them having that uh
that drippy kitten you feel me and um
so or or do you like that old-fashioned
that dry rub
so that's what i'm saying interesting
underwater births
or that regular just straight into the
air animal
gang buzz buzz
love it dude the dry rub i like the
dryer that one that was a
tough obstacle for theo to get through
that one
bus yeah it looked like it hurt for him
to get that out oh it did
it did he i think i would do under
underwater birth is like
you're doing that at home though in the
bathtub i know that's the point it's
221.
yeah why the [ __ ] giving birth at the
crib in the crisib i know
i'm a big fan of the c-section or you
just doesn't ruin the vagina
and it's it's like the kid for sure
comes out ready to go like even if he's
upside down or his record they get them
out
and there's a time like when when i know
that they want to do it natural but
women do
you know they're in labor for 46 hours
it's like you know we could just take
care of this like dude
my kid when my daughter was born my
first daughter was born
her uh mom went into the delivery room
no epi son no epidural just went in full
1700s giving birth and
now now is your girl from the movie
apocalypto yeah
dude she's just she just [ __ ] white
knuckled it
and she dude we're flying home we're
flying home
uh like may 24th to may 25th my kids do
dates like
july 4th like she could potentially give
birth that's not
i didn't think you could even fly no her
doctor her doctor doesn't give a [ __ ]
her doctor's like dude you could do it
that's those new york doctors
that's why our entire nation shut down
things i know but i'm i'm so
nervous about it flying home but she's
like she was like what if if it happens
i'll just give birth
her sister her sister gave birth in
their house
like unexpectedly didn't even call the
doctor sister
and her mother delivered the baby and
then they went to the hospital they
called 9-1-1
dude that's what it is they're gangsters
gangsters dude puerto ricans yep
all right apocalypto wow good movie
apocalypse
[Music]